[Music]
whether it's lamps headphones tables or
chairs
catalonian designer eugenie yet follows
his inspiration wherever it leads at the
salone del mobile he's surrounded by
journalists
not long ago he was voted designer of
the year at the meson eobje fair he's in
milan with italian furniture maker
cartel to present his dream chair a seat
which is completely only connected in
the back and the front
and all the rest stay like a fabric
and all injected in one single piece
kit yet has been coming to the furniture
trade fair in milan for the past 15
years
the salone del mobile is the most
important venue for the designer to
present his newest creations
the best creativity is shown here
so
everybody comes here to see what's going
on in the planet
it's the moment where
you show what you've been working during
one year two years and it's now when the
people see it for the first time and you
can see what is
the the reaction so that's what we do it
for
the salone internationale del mobile in
milan is an institution
every april since 1961 thousands of
designers from around the world have
presented their latest works here
with so much competition it's not easy
to stand out
keith liet has a simple tactic stay true
to your vision
i call myself uh
disognador
and de sonyador is the dreamcatcher in a
way
so i try to translate this vision i have
of
the world of life of a positive way a
beautiful way into objects and share the
objects with everybody
keith lied creates his prototypes in his
office in barcelona he's a very
ambitious person who isn't satisfied
with simply making pretty objects the
designer wants to explore the limits of
the materials he uses
what's important is to
have a story
the story once you have the story it
gives you a general vision
of what you are doing and you just need
to complete and it comes automatically
so every piece comes in a very natural
way
oijani
was born on the spanish island of ibiza
in 1972 and studied design in barcelona
he met trailblazing french designer
philippe stock over a decade and a half
ago and the two launched a long lasting
cooperation that has resulted in
numerous products including the highly
respected master chair for cartel
keith's had an office in barcelona since
2011.
back at the milan furniture fair he gets
commissions from manufacturers around
the world for the spanish company palm
door he's developed an entire bathroom
collection he wants the reflecting
surfaces to create optical illusions
you don't know what is empty
you don't know what is full
everything it's like if water was
falling into the void the intention is
to bring to the bath a new dimension
and
it's not really to have a bath but it's
like a living room
it's a living room in the bath
kit liete says his goal is to make
people happy with his designs while
simplifying their lives that's why many
of his objects fulfill more than one
function
we are always dreaming on all kinds of
products from automobile from tableware
from chairs from bath from light
everything is just be free to create
[Music]
i want one like this for me
a man of vision whose products are once
again gracing the prestigious fair in
milan